for the participants who have just
joined please feel free to introduce
yourself in the chat box with your
educational background and research
interests we will be starting in two
more minutes
all right so let's start with today's
webinar thank you for your responses for
introducing yourself in the chat box
all right so hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all my name is Sri
gauri Krishna gumar and I would like to
welcome you all for today's webinar on
data science for biomedical research so
why do you need data science for
biomedical research biomedical data
science involves the analysis of
large-scale biomedical data sets to
understand how living systems function
the rapid growth of high throughput data
including omics Technologies gave rise
to significant demand for data science
skills and experience along with
bioinformatic methods of analysis that
is why we have designed this online
training program that will cover
practical and conceptual aspects of data
science including data wrangling
statistical analysis and machine
learning in application to high
throughput biomedical omics data using
big data analysis tools such as the
t-bioinfo platform R and python coding
languages
before proceeding further we also have
an exciting announcement about the
upcoming hackathon on microbiome in
health and wellness this is an
initiative to provide students with a
platform to Showcase their Innovative
mindset of problem solving here each
student will have the opportunity to
develop a mini project around the
hackathon topic form a team with at
least two other students and compete
against each other for mentorship
support from established companies and
long-term interest from the business
community
the applications of hackathon will be in
the field of obesity and Precision
Nutrition Innovation and beauty products
and pregnancy so I would like to urge
all the participants to be a part of
this hackathon and make the most out of
such a wonderful opportunity if you wish
to know more about the event details you
can visit the link that will be provided
to you by one of our team members
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program we are a us-based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and Commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
the Omens logic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and Regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program Logistics and adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world this
training has been completed by
participants in six different
specialization tracks which includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine Neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omix data analysis
so how do omicstogic resources help
Advance bioinformatics teaching omics
logic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
it takes a combination of training
modules data analysis tools curated
project data sets and interactive
sessions with mentors to give the
student a clear path of the Bloom's
taxonomy permit no matter what the
user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omic's logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets and introduction to basic coding
languages such as R and python or even
beginning a data analysis project
the program comes with an access to the
omics logic courses which includes
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multi-omics which includes
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
and epigenomics data science that
includes bioinformatics using RN python
as well as cheminformatics
and example projects of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research work users will be
given directions to access the T by info
platform for bioinformatics processing
and Analysis of data the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run bioinformatics
pipelines different stages of the
analysis are performed in different
sections on this multi-ohmics platform
so first of all let's begin by signing
up on the omics logic learn portal
before that let me walk you through a
brief demo on what a completed profile
on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features you need to update on
your account that is a completed profile
will have a profile image full name with
appropriate capitalization link to your
social media handles which could be your
Facebook LinkedIn Instagram or kaidi or
even Twitter and a brief bio about
yourself that will consist of your
educational background and research
interest the matters can view your
progress under the activity tab the
courses you are currently completing
will appear under the courses Tab and
finally after the completion of your
course the certificates will appear
under the certificate stack so with that
let us Begin by signing up on the portal
I'm sharing the link in the chat box
please click on the link and I'll walk
you through the process behind signing
up on the omixological learn portal
so here is the link
for users who do not have an existing
account on the portal please click on
the create an account option that you
see here
so here you will be asked to enter your
name email ID and provide a password you
also have the option to sign up using
any of your social media accounts which
could be your Google account Facebook
account app to account GitHub account or
even your Twitter and with that I'll
pause for a couple of minutes for the
participants to sign up once you have
signed up please put a yes in the chat
box and if you're facing any technical
issues for signing up on the portal you
can share that in the chat and our team
will be happy to help you so I'm
monitoring the chat once the
participants have signed up please put a
yes
[Music]
foreign
you can put that in the chat as well and
I'll be happy to help you
so meanwhile since I already have an
account on the portal I'm going to click
on login now option that you see here
and click on the sign in option all
right one person has signed up I'm
waiting for rest of the 20 plus
participants
so once you sign up on the portal you
are able to see the various courses and
example projects that you can browse
through after the webinar gets over so
since most of the participants are
interested in data science let us enter
the keyword data science and see what
are all the courses and example projects
that will appear as you can see there
are a lot of quotes on python or cores
as well as example projects that you can
go through now the most important step
that I discussed previously was setting
up the profile so for that click on the
tab that says welcome back with your
email ID
and here you will be able to see the
feature uh profile edit icon here you
will be able to edit each of the
features that you wish to upload on your
account so here you can insert your
educational background and your research
interest and in my case I've linked my
LinkedIn account and my I or Kylie so
here under the activity tab the mentor
and the community manager of the program
will be able to track your learning
progress and once you start completing
the courses it will appear under the
courses Tab and once you complete a
project and upload it on the portal it
will appear under the projects Tab and
once you enroll for any of the program
for example the data science for
biomedical research program it will
appear under the programs Tab and
finally when you complete any of the
courses it it will the certificates will
appear under the certificates tab so
with that if anyone has any queries
please put them in the chat box
otherwise we can now move on to the
next part of the webinar which will be
taken over by Dr raghav Who is the
mentor and research consultant at Pine
biotech
over to you sir
thank you very much SRI gowri so while
you are busy signing up let me find ways
to share my screen and set up for
today's
presentation
so can you see my screen
and can you hear me clearly yes yes
about our friend okay thank you very
much so let's uh
okay
let me welcome you one more time for
today's session today is the first
session for the data science for
biomedical research and uh you can set
up the chat box so that I can follow you
responding to my queries
or if you have any questions please type
them as we go along in today's session
so in this program we generally we will
focus on the methods for the analysis of
big data and data wrangling and data
pre-processing and data Pro analytics
skills for bioinformatization as well as
those who are interested in other types
of non-biology related research analysis
using the data science or data analysis
methods that we will be focusing in this
program
so in today's session we are going to
discuss about some of the key topics
overview of the key topics and we will
discuss about uh what is the data that
we are going to be analyzing uh we are
going to discuss about what is the type
of the data uh that we are going to be
covering and we'll touch upon data data
loading and data preparation slightly
and uh we will also uh briefly uh Breeze
through some of the statistical tests
that we can perform on the data and we
can also discuss upon what where to find
this data couple of slides on where to
find this data and generally in this
data science program what are the omics
data types that we are going to use for
our analysis and our understanding of
the different data analytics methods
that we are going to use
so
what is data science right data science
can be ah
thought about or can be abstracted as a
convergence of data management data
manipulation and analytical methods for
this hypothesis testing in any
specialized domain and at this time for
the bioinformatics and for biology bio
medical related research the domain is
the biology and the methods that we are
going to use mainly based on statistical
analytical methods and informatics tools
to manage the data that is going to flow
into these methods and that's going to
come out of these data analytical types
to infer important questions important
biomedical research and biomedical
related questions to understand
patterns to understand the disease
biology and to understand various
different questions that one can set up
using the data and using the research
theme itself right and basically because
of these methods we will also uh
encounter and we will also discuss that
the uh the domain biology itself is
rapidly acquiring the characteristics of
data science
and when I speak about that biology in
today's era contains billions and
billions of data points on genes
proteins and other molecules and these
data points are compiled in large files
and are systematically studied to
understand the patterns in the data this
type of analyzing the data will actually
lead to more knowledge and more
understanding about human health about
biology biotechnology in general about
agriculture and about livestock and
various other different
um
uh research areas so this huge volume of
data and its influx actually generated
tremendous development in Associated
methodologies and these together has
completely changed the biological
research towards the data driven
data-driven researcher data driven
approach for making
bioinformatics for life science as one
of the prominent
methods to understand biology and such
right so this is completely different
from what has been traditionally
practiced in biology as biology has
traditionally been a hypothesis based on
the data collection based
research domain
so over the past 20 years as as I
mentioned there has been a phenomenal
growth in the adoption of high
throughput sequencing Technologies and
high throughput Technologies like next
Generation sequencing
um in research in clinical practice in
biotechnology and biological Pharma
industry sectors and these adoption of
these technology has actually produced
an exponential growth of data that is
publicly available
and these data are
commonly referred to as omics data this
trend has actually produced a big data
problem that preludes many clinicians
and many biologists from understanding
knowledge and understanding pattern from
this data regarding the nature of for
example malignant tumor and malignant
processes and the relationship between
clinical phenotypes and their molecular
drivers behind them
yeah
foreign
so for example if you take in today's
era or in the last three or four years
the due to the pandemic and due to the
availability of the methods to sequence
and we can generally see this phenomenal
growth or phenomenal increase in the
volume of genomic data or full genome
sequence data specific to covid-19 or
coronavirus when you compare it with the
other well-known virus that has been
already studied until now
so we spoke about omics data omics data
generally includes phenomics genomics
epigenomics and Technologies like next
Generation sequencing and high
throughput sequencing can actually be
used to explore the roles the
relationships and the actions of various
types of molecules that make up the
cells of an organism many types of these
atomics data can be generated using MGS
method and what is also commonly
referred to as high throughput
sequencing methods and these data can
actually show detailed information about
patterns of the gene expression and
isoform expression detailed information
about genomic variance and its effects
in the phenotype or in the disease
biology and general information about
for example
um
uh
amount or level of Gene gene expression
patterns and gene expression uh counts
in relationship to the disease biology
in general
so we discussed earlier that
bioinformatics and biology actually
acquires the properties of data science
now to give you a brief overview of data
science we know that data science
involve uh involves developing methods
of recording storing and analyzing data
to effectively extract meaningful and
useful information the goal of the data
science is to gain insights and to gain
knowledge from any type of data this
type of data or this data can generally
be structured or unstructured or
semi-structured unstructured data is
what you typically have to deal with and
when you are acquiring publicly
available data and this unstructured
data has to be prepared for analysis or
pre-processed for analysis to make it
useful and to make it applicable to a
variety of different methods that you
will be learning over the course of this
program to apply to different omics
Logics or not omics different omics data
types so to give you an example of what
is an unstructured data and how to
force or how to gain structure from this
structure data we can have couple of
illustrations so for example if I ask
you what is your educational background
and if I let the answer column
completely open and free you will we
will have variety of different responses
ranging from one word answer to
um to a small passage describing what
you are studying and what are your in
what are your interests and what are
your main area of focus but these
responses will be very easy for any
human to understand but for
computational computers and for
information information
um processing to make sense out of this
data is very challenging so what do we
do we force structure onto the data that
you are going to collect if how can we
force uh structure we can tend or we can
change the survey replace the survey
into categories that we can easily
analyze count and use our subject that
to different statistical methods so when
we do this we are forcing structure into
this unstructured data for
um to enable us data interpretation and
data analytics to understand the variety
and Trend in the data so that we can
make sense of what we intended to start
with time
that and to visualize data also uh this
is actually usually done so this
analyzed data and visualized data can
easily be shared easily be interpreted
and easily be understood generally but
if you take the unstructured data it's
difficult to make sense out of the
results uh through computational methods
this example or this instance or this uh
this illustration would be true for any
kind of data and especially big data so
big data has certain characteristics
that we have to keep in mind it has
velocity variability and volume all of
these has been uh we can
illustrate in the SARS kovid 2
availability of genome
coronavirus genome example that we spoke
about couple of slides support So before
three years ago or three years ago we
hardly had any coronavirus or source
code with a genome at the scale at the
velocity at the speed under the variance
that we can analyze these uh information
now so this this is typical example of
what the available technology and the
availability of methods can do to the
data that can be generated and that has
been generated big data that has been
generated in an extra simple foreign
[Music]
data to understand the processes and to
understand the trends in the data so how
to structure omics data in order to
structure omics data we need to take the
raw sequencing data output that is in
the strings of letter a t g and c and we
have to generate a matrix or a data set
of a combination of a continuous and
categorical data that can be analyzed
using statistical methods to do this we
organize a specific set of processing
steps in sequences that we often refer
to as pipeline analysis Pipeline and
these are specific to each types of
omics data so when we speak about data
processing as a procedure to generate
data sets or structured data we can
term these analysis methods as specific
data analysis methods like genomics
pipeline or genomics data analysis
method takes the unstructured genomics
data that is in unstructured sequence
data that is usually stored in fastq
file format and then applies structure
to this data and similarly we can apply
structure to sequence data that is
intended to measure transcriptomics Gene
abundance or Gene Gene quantification
and intended to measure methylation data
for Gene regulation and
etc etc
so to to to be able to run complex
bioinformatics pipelines you need high
performance Computing or cloud-based
servers without slowing down your own
computer right so in order to understand
or you're not to develop a logical
understanding of many methods involving
this data preparation we have a specific
set of
courses and lessons that will show you
how to set up these analysis pipeline in
order to generate the structured data
from this unstructured data many of you
who are new to bioinformatics and who
are interested in these processes are
free to explore this also
so there are commonly used methods to
study for example DNA variation and
sequence pipelines to study understand
genomic variation gene expression
protein abundance and compositional
properties of microbial communities all
of these are different types of data
that we will learn to explore and we
will learn to mine for patterns to
understand the trends in the data
related to the biological condition or
disease biology or phenotypical
characteristics of the sample that we
started with
so we will also look at full overview of
the data science
methods to understand how different
stages of analysis work together to help
Define the hypothesis to help prepare
the data for Meaningful applications of
statistical methods like machine
learning and practical challenges so in
this flowchart for example you would
assume that most of the time in mesh in
data science methods are spent in the
data analysis section but in fact you
will learn that most of the time and
most of the analysis and most of the
effort will be dedicated to this section
where we have to process the data and
explore the data in order to set up the
perfect analysis method that will help
us understand the patterns to answer the
hypothesis or to answer the question
that we have set up at the start of the
experimental design so you will also
learn different methods to process the
data different methods to visualize the
data for exploratory data analysis and
different methods to analyze the data
that suits you your research question
that suits your research hypothesis
so we spoke about structuring the data
so let's go through couple of examples
of how to structure different types of
data like genomics data transcriptomics
data and metagenomic Theta and what will
you get at the end of these analysis
methods and what is the structured data
that you will get your hands on that you
can apply a variety of different
statistical methods that include machine
learning methods that you will be
frequently applying in this program
so to achieve some of the results we are
going to take for example in genomics
data analysis we will take the first few
files with short trees and run a
pipeline an example pipeline called
variant calling pipeline to get an
output of tables all to get a variant
called a VCF file of that lists all the
genomic variants that is present in the
sample that you have sequenced compared
to the reference sequence that we have
generally available at the repositories
or the library is
so this processes involves mapping and
identifying somatic variant calling
steps to produce a table that we can
analyze or a list of these variants
for example when this shotgun sequencing
methods or pipeline is used we will
generate lot of short reads that are to
be mapped on to these specific sections
of the reference sequence that are that
can that you can see here since we have
zoomed out so far we cannot read the
reference sequence but these horizontal
bars are the stretches of sequences in
your sample that are short read so when
you go through the genomics data
analysis you can understand what we are
actually talking to so but then at the
end of this analysis methods the aim is
to identify variances in your reads or
the newer sample compared to the
compared to the reference sequence or
compared to the reference that we are
comparing with so at the end for example
in
thank you
can you hear me now yeah so in the end
for example in uh for example in
oncology we will categorize the
non-matches and we will categorize
matches for their mutational status and
are often we can categorize them into
somatic mutations or germline mutations
to understand how important and how
um how they affect some of the genes
involved with tumor growth and tumor
disease progression in general so to
analyze such a data we will need a need
to prepare a table of somatic scores or
mutational index for each genomic
position this is a this is a table or
structured table that one can generally
obtain at the end of the genomics data
analysis that you can subject to a
variety of different
statistical analysis and machine
learning analysis to understand the
importance of this genomic importance of
this mutational index or importance of
these mutational frequency at each and
every genomic position
my
[Music]
okay it is now responded so so another
example of uh another example of such
data omics data is transcriptomics data
which represents the MRNA expression in
a to analyze what is the process going
on inside the cell by observing active
transcription of protein coding genes
right the DNA first is actually
transcribed into RNA and RNA is
translated into protein in inside the
cell as we generally know and we have
um
yeah we have our exposure to different
protein synthesis process inside the
cell
so this process has an innate
variability that is associated with
producing alternative splicing or
producing different Exon skipping that
will generate isoforms and genes
variants of the genes that that one can
easily associate with the disease
biology are recently associated with the
phenotype phenotype of the samples and
etc etc it is very important to quantify
the level of expression of these
alternatively spliced variants of a
single Gene and these different
different genes in in specific in order
to understand their effect and their
importance and their mechanism that
drives for example tumor growth tumor
progression and disease biology Etc
so a typical analysis for the pipeline
analysis pipeline for rna-seq data are
transcriptomics data analysis goes like
this where you will first pre-process
the data by cleaning out some of that
data sequences followed by mapping the
reads onto the reference genome to
understand how genes are expressed and
what variations in alternative splicing
can lead to transcripts that will Define
a pipe Define a phenotype and then in
the end you will
um
you will quantify the reads that are
mapped onto specific genes and their
isoforms so this results in a table of
continuous numerical data that is
annotated by Gene ID along the rows and
the sample ID along the columns for any
given experiment and at their
intersection you will get a gene
expression level that is specific to
that particular Gene ID and this
particular sample name so this is
another example of a structured data
that you will take in order to apply to
different statistical methods to
understand the pattern for example you
can use data mining approaches to study
the study the segregation and to study
the sample order and you can apply for
example machine learning analysis like
supervised machine learning to classify
the samples into predefined classes and
etc etc
one another type of data that I told we
will be discussing uh is is a data that
comes from same sequencing technique
that is high throughput sequencing
technique but offers a completely
different view of the biological sample
that we are considering in this case we
are not looking at one specific sample
or one specific organism we are looking
at a collection or a working at a
community of millions of microorganisms
that is represented by genomes that are
very different from each other in order
to structure this data and to organize
this genomic information into categories
we can take functionally related Gene
that is common to all of the organisms
like ribosome Gene which is compared to
a database of known sequences to for
example identify the ah identify the
identity of these microbes that are
present in the sample that we have
collected so this can be applied or this
can um this analysis is commonly
referred to as 16s rrna amplicon data
analysis and can be performed like other
analysis methods in the pbio info
platform using data 2 or time to
pipeline that we uh we are we usually
refer to so as a result of this analysis
you can obtain proportions of taxonomic
groups across samples
um with the analysis of sample diversity
or with the analysis of disease biology
or different phenotypes in general so if
you start with understanding meta
genomics or microbial population
differences between two different
phenotypic phenotypes of the sample then
we will we will find ways to relate and
understand the pattern related to these
different phenotypes if you want to
understand the disease biology then we
will take metagenomics or microbial
Community sample from people who are
infected with the disease and people who
are free from the disease and this
becomes a comparison in general so
yeah
so this data again this data analysis
again uh results and basic type of
structure data that is resulting uh from
this type of analysis is referred to as
otu table that is operational taxonomic
unit table table across the sample with
proportional abundance in each and every
cell so instead of Gene IDs that that
you that we spoke about in the
transcriptomics data you will have
operational taxonomic unit or root use
across the rows and samples across the
columns under their intersection you
will find abundance of that specific
taxonomic unit which is a species that
is a group of species the related
species at the level of genomic identity
uh percentage defined by us while
analyzing so another information that
one can obtain from this analysis is the
identity of these four to use in general
the otus are linked to their abundance
levels in the previous table and their
identity is actually calculated from the
um by comparing the
sequence that is sequenced with the
database of sequences of all the
organisms and there
um
phylum taxonomic groups of Kingdom like
kingdom phylum class order family Gene
species are actually identified and
fabulated this together with the
previous structured data we will take
and we will analyze and look for
patterns of abundance level across
different family order or phylum at the
different rank that we want to
understand their patterns in the biology
of our samples so how would you go about
doing this so we discussed along the way
one of the key steps in performing these
data science and data analytics methods
of Home Etc is to generate a structured
data once you have this structured data
we can actually load up these structured
data into an environment like r or
python in order to understand their
pattern and to subject to variety of
different statistical methods and to
make a different visualization options
from the data that we have in general so
this can be loaded into a
two-dimensional
um
table and that table cannot be a matrix
because over the course of last few
slides I showed you that this data may
contain
um columns that are full of numbers
columns that has
um characters or that has identity uh in
terms of Gene IDs and columns that has
otu identity so we have a collection or
we have a table that has a collection of
different data types usually such an
information is loaded into an object
called Data frame in r or python which
we will explore in much detail so any
data that has a collection of more than
one type of data right and that can be
loaded into a data frame object and
while when you have a data that has
specific data type associated with that
you have to use something like a vector
or a matrix or array depending upon the
dimension of the data in order to load
them and to process and analyze them
while we also will encounter some other
data types like objects like a list
which contains a multitude of different
data types at different dimensions
generally we will not use list and until
and unless we are going to perform
specific data analysis many a time we
will load the structured data into a
data frame object and then process this
data frame to represent a matrix or to
represent a vector that can be that can
be applied to different statistical and
visualization tools and Analysis
so this is called preparing the data
yes this is called preparing the data
yesterday if you have free questions
free some questions from the
participants please put them up in the
chat box I cannot read them for some
reason
okay sure uh
first query is uh do you offer courses
in BIO python
the python module that we have will also
include bio python right uh we do have
we do have a couple of lessons that
involve biopython in loading sequences
and to analyze these sequences and their
uh and their uh
uh identity and similarity levels but we
will use a variety of different python
tools like scikit and uh
uh yeah scikit methods for General data
analysis methods right uh biopython is
used mainly when you have a lot of
sequence related information like you
can use biopython for VCF calling
variant calling file reading and their
analysis but we are going to deal with a
lot of Downstream analysis after you
have generated the structured table so
that might not have lot of sequence data
but uh
using bio python related analysis is
just one extension of what you can learn
here so we will be dealing with a lot of
machine learning analysis that can be
performed on the omics data and the
structured data that you will generate
from here so bio python is just one
phase or one module that can be used to
analyze such data
and do you also have options for
proteomics course using AI we do not
have options for proteomics course using
AI at the moment
um
communicate Festus if I am if I did not
butcher your name so um but we do have
other omics data type and we do have
um methods to integrate
um
these different data types that will
also include proteomics data types right
at the end of proteomics data or at the
end of proteomics data analysis also if
you are going to get a structured table
then that structure table can be used
and that structure can date table can be
applied to different variety of
different machine learning data science
methods that we will be seeing and that
we will be performing in this program so
far
so any other question yes recovery has
another question uh I am analyzing
microbiome data using data 2 but I got
stuck at the stage where I have to
perform phyloc object can you oh this is
very specific question can you check the
code for me please get in touch with our
support group at supported fine dot bio
and then we will discuss what we can
offer to you okay uh I did not get the
name of the person who uh
who has this query and any other
questions
no sir that will be all thank you okay
so let's let's move forward so for
example uh we spoke about uh preparing
the data which is an important process
in uh process towards uh process after
structuring the data and applying to
different statistical methods so we will
learn how to prepare data and we will
learn how to use different plotting
tools like histograms catapults
byproducts to find relationships in the
data and explore ways to characterize
millions of data points per sample right
why do we need to do this we have to do
this in order to understand the pattern
so that once you have an idea of what is
a pattern that you are observing in the
data then you can set up specific
analysis methods to answer the question
that you want to choose for example if I
see a generalized pattern that I have
three separate clusters of samples that
in in my data or my data segregates the
samples into three separate clusters
then I can spend time and more effort in
characterizing these specific clusters
by applying classification tools or
applying unsupervised clustering methods
unsupervised machine learning methods to
understand what is specific to each of
these clusters that I can use for
further biological interpretation of
these clusters and naming of these
clusters of samples this is fairly
commonly used in analysis of
any omics data type related to tumor
samples where the effort is mainly to
understand the multitude or understand
the variety of different tumor types
that is that one can associate with any
specific tumor samples and omics omics
data type is one way to observe their
segregation into these different
histological types or these different
molecular subtypes of tumors and or any
other
pattern that can differentiate the tumor
data that can differentiate the atomic
data of this tumor based on their
segregation this pattern can also
include for example clinical data like
demographic data like the age
differences in this in the in the
patients it can also include the
treatment responses so these are all
some of the examples that some of the
examples and some of the instances which
you will be analyzing in the program
when in the program as we go along
so to understand this we will use for
example yeah to understand this we will
use visual representation to spot for
example technical noise that is
important to be eliminated using various
normalization techniques and data
transformation steps and the choice of
these normalization data transformation
steps will vary and has to change
depending upon the data that you have
chosen and the data that you have you
are analyzing and the pattern that you
will get
we will also speak about making machine
learning models more transparent and
explainable whenever we present data to
our collaborators and to and to share
with other
peers so without peers right this is
extremely important in the era where
more and more research and efforts are
going are spent towards translational
approach of any data analysis so we have
to make the models more explainable in
terms of basic data that has been
collected if you are collecting or if
you are analyzing transcriptomics data
the model the machine learning model
that we have built should give you or
should result you in a set of important
genes that are very very important that
are crucial to perform these accurate
classification if you are for example
analyzing genomic variance data the
machine learning model or unsupervised
clustering that you have built should
actually explain which mutations are
prominent and are very important in
classifying these samples into these
different clusters that we we have
identified
so we will also have specific chance and
we will also have lot of opportunity to
see how different data mining methods
and machine learning methods are used to
group data objects by for example
feature similarity or similar expression
patterns of genes and we will spend lot
of methods to train a model for
predictive analysis and we will see what
are the different data mining approaches
like hierarchical clustering k-means
clustering and how they differ in in
analyzing your data and what is the main
underlying analysis method that
differentiates these two different
data mining approaches and we will also
discuss a variety of different
classification machine learning tools
like ranging from as simple as decision
trees to as complex as random Forest
methods and
while discussing svm ldas stepwise LDA
increasing the order of difficulty in
the complexity to understand how these
different methods and when and where to
use these different methods depending
upon the data so it depends upon the
volume of the data it depends upon the
variety of data as we spoke about and
depends upon depending upon these
characteristics of the data you have to
choose appropriate Data Mining and
classification tools for the model and
for the analysis that you are building
and all of these we will discuss with
specific project examples and
publication examples on curated data
sets and publicly available data assets
also so that you can get a good handle
about a handle on the methods that are
used and the questions that it is
related to and the type of analysis that
is being developed for this and
answering the question
so uh how do we do that at the basic or
at the um at the heart of all this is to
load the data and visualize this data
using uh relationships and spotting
relationships and patterns in the
complex data so we will go through some
of the uh or at least one specific
code lesson to give you an idea how this
lesson in R is actually structure so let
me reshare my screen
uh
so how to do that with a stop share
okay that is my zoom
yeah sugary can you see my screen can
everybody see my screen
yes sir we are seeing the program page
yes that's what I that is what is the
intended so this is a program page where
we have all the other uh Associated
resources so for the resources that we
are discussing today
um
we will go about
yeah we will go about data processing
and visualization and yeah so you can
check some of the associated resources
in
in this visualization
yeah this is the lesson one loading data
in r
so this lesson is actually structured
this lesson is actually structured as a
section to understand the code learn the
code and where each and every piece of
code is actually
um
properly commented and properly
annotated to tell you what different
parts of this code do and how we can for
example load data onto the onto these uh
into the platform like R and Python and
we have sections where you can try the
code that you have learned so far so
this actually runs on a r console that
is loaded when you load this program
page when you wrote These lessons in the
back end so for example in this practice
code what have we done is we have
actually erased or we have actually
um made deliberate mistakes in the
syntaxes and in the uh
commands that you will need to run these
code successfully so if you run this
specific code as it is it's going to
throw you an error and most of the time
this error is not going to be meaningful
as it is with many programming language
so it's important to read through what
is the intended challenge to practice in
this specific area so it says you have
to copy the file link here copy link
address and then paste it here
so that
we can refer to the input data that is
going to be loaded
so I paste it so that now the input data
is specified let's clear the console
output and then run it again
again it gives me an error this is
because we have made some of uh missing
parts or we have deliberately deleted
some portion of the syntax so that you
will get you can spot it and then make
couple make necessary changes as you
have learned from the learn the code
section so it goes to
read.table and uh
again I clear this and then run this
so now you get success in running the
code and answer is correct many a times
you will also see that sometimes you
will get responses like success in
running the code but answer is incorrect
that would mean this there is no problem
in the syntax but that could be specific
answer that we are expecting you to
produce from these code um code blocks
that you will have to check your codes
to produce uh to uh to exactly address
the specific part of challenge that we
want you to uh go go with so that is
what I wanted to show you today in terms
of how this
um
how this is actually organized and let
me reshare my screen
can you see my screen
uh no sir we can't see your screen
because I also cannot see this
oh I I think I got it I was starting a
different portion
yes now can you see my screen I think I
got confirmation and you can also see my
screen yes so we can now see okay
perfect so this is this is a snapshot or
a screenshot of what uh you can do with
the coding uh lessons and this is the
same organization for both R and python
courses so for example exactly what you
saw in R is a is replicated in Python
where you will learn the code and you
will address necessary uh we will
address unnecessary parts of these codes
and you will have separate section where
you will load python console and then
fulfill or actually uh perform or work
on these challenges to complete the
challenges successfully
right so what do we want to do how do we
want to do this so in order to
understand the application of all we
have discussed so far we will be able to
uh share with you couple of specific uh
research projects and uh that is
referenced or that that we take from uh
publicly available resources and we get
uh from uh Publications that you will uh
you will be redirected to right for
example in this publication I'm not
going to go over with a lot of details
um if you read through this you will get
information about what are the methods
that are being used what are the data
type that are being used so we will take
this publication and take not all the
data but a curated list of data and
perform some of the data analysis
methods in order to verify their
findings or in order to reach at a
different finding uh that that we have
set up or we have started to analyze
this data
so for example in this specific
publication they have used a lot of
um omix data types like uh seven
different molecular profiling omics data
types and then associate that with the
um
treatment response data in terms of ic50
values and then perform multi-ohmics
data integration not to study treatment
responses for several of the patients
that they have
analyzed so we will take this data and
then discuss by increasing the by
building up the level of complexities
and increasing the integration of
different atomics data type in order to
First understand the patterns of the
omics data or structured data at its
simplest level we take one data type
study the pattern and then we we apply
more sophisticated analytics method and
study how the patterns are evolving and
then we can build upon this method by
including some more uh one another
molecular or mixed data type and then
finally we will merge two or three
different uh
multi-omics data types to understand uh
their pattern in the relationship to
treatment response for example in this
specific project
so this and many other uh information is
available over right throughout the
program page and you are free to check
out the program page and
um and what the program has to offer so
with that I conclude and I actually give
the session Podium back to Sri gauri or
sonalika who is going to take over
so we do have few more queries that is
asking what are your suggestions for
beginners about how to understand the
big data I am not for from IT background
just starting with studying C plus plus
I think you have to start with the
courses like introduction to
bioinformatics and bytes and molecules
so what these two courses are defined or
what these two courses are designed to
do is to introduce you to generally what
big data bioinformatics is and what are
the different domains and research
fields that they are applied to and what
are the for example n translational end
product that you are going to get by
applying these methods and these uh to
these data to different research fields
for example in the health sector the
idea is to improve the diagnosis and
improve the prognosis prediction of the
deceased patients and to understand
which or to apply that to Precision
medicine or personalized medicine where
you can identify patients who are going
to respond to any treatment that is
being considered so this is these types
of relationship between the data the
method and the domain and the
application is actually given in the
introduction to bioinformatics course
and bytes and molecule scores after by
the end of these two courses you are
expected to get a clearer picture of
your interest in terms of domain in
terms of research field in terms of data
analysis methods and in terms of data in
general once you have this clarity
then you can probably sign up for this
specific data science course where we
will focus on the analytics method that
is supplied to a variety of different
Atomic data types as I actually
mentioned to you about or if your idea
or if you are understanding or if your
focus is towards uh gaining extensive
analysis uh knowledge of knowledge in
analysis methods and different methods
to specific data types then we have
programs that addresses
addresses that point also we have
specific genomic data analysis program
we have specific transcriptomics program
and we have other programs that you want
to check out and their announcements and
Etc so
uh yeah I think that partially answers
to your question so uh if you are new to
bioinformatics and you again I have
another question in similar line I will
take um a diwali's question also he you
have knowledge in IIT but no knowledge
in biology you and and anybody who wants
to get an introduction to bioinformatics
so should start with introductory
courses like introduction to
bioinformatics and the Bison molecule so
you will have plenty of exposure to Big
Data by informatics and different
methods and different research field as
we mentioned to you about so if you have
knowledge in it and if you want to learn
how these bioinformatics
process senses methods are actually
applied to biological data without
spending a lot of effort in
understanding the underlying biology I
think you can this data science program
can actually suit you very well because
it is going to give you what are the
necessary
um for example uh perspective that you
need to that you need to address and
that you need to focus on in applying
the known data science methods that you
might have already have um knowledge in
to be able to successfully handle omics
data types and Big Data bioinformatics
data right there are some basic
um underlying data structural
differences in in economics data types
that we will specifically address and
how they actually drive the choice of
method a choice of
analysis methods and choice of different
uh
analytical methods and choice of
classification algorithms and
unsupervised algorithms also depending
upon
um the structure of the data for example
to give you one specific examples in any
internet of things or in any financial
data you will have the number of
observations to be huge a number of
features to be very low but in the omics
data types in structuredomics data type
that we have discussed the number of
observations is fairly low and while the
number of features is extraordinarily
high so this proposes a specific
challenge that you need to address while
setting up the parameters for and no
with very well known unsupervised and
supervised machine learning algorithms
and even any statistical analysis
methods also that we will focus mainly
and in detail in handling data and how
to pre-process and how to work around
this problem to understand patterns in
the omics data types
and yeah any other queries so far
and Dr was asking share the r codes here
please yes as I as I showed you in the
associated resource you will get info
you will get all the codes when you sign
up for the program uh present in the
lesson themselves in terms of python
again the same but in Python you will
also get
access to specific jupyter notebook or
collaboratory notebook that we have
prepared for the analysis methods that
this collaboratory notebook can also
contain some of additional assignments
and challenges if you are that you are
encouraged to
attempt that right all these R codes
that we have been that I I showed you in
the lessons that you will get free
access to and you can copy and paste
not of course you can copy and paste in
your own analysis uh
environment and apply that if if you
want specific analysis methods to be
discussed in detail then we have right
throughout the program we have
um live Q and A sessions at
scheduled at different time and please
do attend those q a sessions these live
q a sessions right throughout this
program are for discussing what you have
gone through and if you have any
specific queries regarding one specific
analysis type that we have not covered
in detail or that is not a popular
choice then we can we can focus on those
analysis methods and Analysis queries in
in detail right for example we mainly
focus on all the analysis types that are
successfully applied to
bioinformatics data and the biological
data economics data type in general but
we can also compare different analysis
methods in this application also so you
are encouraged to do that and for
example if you need templates for
specific R codes then we might have that
in other parts of our lessons that I can
point to where to get from right
and any other queries
uh I'm I do not belong to bioinformatics
or IIT sorry I.T can you tell once again
what is this what this R code is
um antisha Harvest R is a programming
language uh just like Python and whose
environment you will Ex you will exploit
to analyze this data so we spoke about
and I gave you
um examples of structured data and
showed you load that data into Excel by
highlighting what happens or what are
the entries in the rows and what are the
entries in the column right and this
visualization of this data can be
performed on basic graphing can be
plotted in tools like Excel but it stops
there in order to understand the complex
patterns of this structured data you
have to take this data and apply some
sophisticated statistical analysis
methods in in an environment that is is
suitable to do that so our programming
language and Python programming language
is couple of such environments right you
can load this file as a table or assist
as an object into these programming
environment and apply variety of
different methods and statistical
analysis that we have been discussing in
order to understand the pattern of the
data and relate that to the biology of
the data that it has been recorded so
that is what R and python in a nutshell
and how they are involved in this
processes right if you want more
information you will have more
information in our section in our
lessons also where we have dedicated
courses on uh
on
on R and python as a part of
introductory introduction to our
interaction introductor three courses to
python where we start from the basic
level of setting up r or installing R in
your computer setting up and installing
python in your computer and what are the
basic commands that you will need to get
familiarized with to understand the data
types that is related to the biological
data and bioinformatics data and by
slowly building up the complexity to
push yourself to this level where you
are free
familiar uh where you're familiar
familiarity increases to the level of
pre-processing the omics data type and
in a necessary
course in a yeah in a to a necessary
level where it can be applied to variety
of different methods so what do we have
another question is there a certificate
of attendance I think SRI gauri can
answer that
um what are the limitations of using
statistical tools like SPSS Innovation
and Matlab
um there are no limitations of using
statistical tools like SPSS but uh the
innate graphical user interface that you
will use with SPSS file and I have no
idea with in Vivo stat and in order to
make it user friendly and in order to
confine the statistical methods into a
GUI that you use for SPSS for example
SPSS comes with certain limitations and
not a full Liberty in terms of what you
can use and how you can use it right for
example I am not very sure about
programming in SPSS to apply the same
data analysis methods over and over
again in in a loop environment or in a
loop for multiple variety of different
comparative methods right that that
might not be possible in a spaces or
might be possible in SPSS but SPSS is
basically or is confined to agree any
programming method that is confined to
agree comes with their own set of
challenges that needs to be addressed
and Matlab I don't think I have we have
any problem with Matlab but Matlab is
not free
that is why we do not focus on matlab's
version or use of Matlab for these
methods and Analysis anything that you
can do with r and python or most of the
things that you can earn that you can do
with r and python you can do with Matlab
but as I mentioned Matlab is not free
okay I think that will answer most of
the questions and over to you SRI gauri
yes sir so we have like few more queries
for sonalika that is do we get
recordings of the session and also will
there be a participation certificate
yes their
um will be the participation
certificates and also we are going to
share the recording with all the
participants uh who have joined today's
session via an email
so that will answer your question as are
there any other questions for me or can
I pick up the registration part now yes
we have several queries regarding the
registration scholarship as well as for
the entry requirements so over to you
yeah why are you just go through that
now thank you so much
Dr raghav and now I would like to take
up the registration part how do you get
started with this program how do you
enroll yourself and what are the
available scholarships so here is the
program page I've shared in the chat box
as well once you visit this program page
we have put together everything
including the schedule and also the
registration link so here is uh the
sessions schedule where you can see on
which all dates the sessions are
scheduled to be
hosted live and then you have here the
details of the topics that will be
covered in each one of these sessions
and the associated resources that you
need to cover as a part of this session
search Dr raghav mentioned that there
are several resources that you leverage
from as a part of this program so you
have to go through these course works on
the omixologic learn portal and as a
part of each one of these sessions your
supposed to complete some of these
lessons including the quizzes and
assignments as well so we have listed
them out here and once the session is
complete the recording will be uploaded
on the program page it will also be
emailed to all the participants but it
will also be there on the program page
so you need to complete the associated
resources revisit the recording or watch
the recording and click on a complete
session button that will pop up once the
session is completed and doing so will
help you get a certificate on your
profile tab
now they these are the list of all the
sessions that you can read through as a
part of this program and get the
information on what are we going to
cover for the program the program starts
on September 28th that is we'll be
having our first session there at the
same time now if you scroll down you'll
get three levels which you can pick and
register for we have a subscription
level for 45 days then we then you can
either subscribe for 60 days or 90 days
so these different days of subscription
types comes with different accessibility
to the resources that we have on the
Onyx logic gland portal the DeBary info
server and also the mentorship so if you
take up the 45 days of the enrollment
duration for your program then you will
be a part of the training program where
you will be a part of these live
sessions go through the asynchronous
coursework watch the recordings and then
if you want to apply your knowledge on a
research problem in hand then you can
maybe join the 60 days of the
subscription level where you will get to
work on a research question with the
mentor and plan your research proposal
to get started with your research
project and in the 90 days of duration
you'll be able to complete your training
and then also work on a research project
and publish it successfully if you get
the required number of us in a day for
the program
so that is about the three types of
durations that you can pick while
registering yourself
either 45 days 60 days or 90 days now
you simply click on this button and
proceed ahead with your registration now
there are several scholarship options
available for the interested
participants I'll quickly share the
scholarship form
in the giant box
so those who are interested for
scholarship please fill out this form
our team will review your application
and get back to you with the possible
scholarships
I mean while I'm sharing this form you
get put your questions in the chat so
that we can assist you or here is the
following
so this was one thing
and then as a part of this program you
have certain courseworks to complete
python course one and python course 2
and also our course on and R course 2.
all right so we have the courses listed
out here as well and on completion of
each one of these sessions you will get
the certificate where do these
certificates come before I jump there I
would like to tell you that if you are
not from a us if you're not from us and
you belong to a different country you
can simply click on this currency icon
here in the main menu bar on top and
speak your currency and if your currency
is not available
so this is the profile section that tree
gauri went through in the beginning of
this particular webinar so if you visit
your profile section and click on the
certificates tab here is where you get
all the certificates so you will be
getting one certificate from for the
program completion and also for each
coursework that you complete you are
going to get a separate certificate and
this profile is a portrayal of your
achievements then you can share anywhere
on the social media accounts like link
and maybe to Showcase your achievements
to recruiters or supervisors where you
wish to enroll for maybe a PhD program
or higher studies or get your job
that was all that I wanted to mention
are there any questions
uh there is one query how much is the
research training on cancer that is
transportomic for chronic disease is
there any available scholarship for low
income I guess the scholarship is
answered so yes the research training
for cancer
yeah so for uh transcriptomics for
chronic diseases program I think you
might have went through uh this
particular program here on the program
page so yes if you click on the programs
tab you will get all the program Pages
listed out here this is one of those
programs which is ongoing right now and
yes you can enroll in it and same goes
for this one as well that you scroll
down uh this session this is the way you
can look at the session recording and
complete the session this is a program
which will be concluded soon so we'll be
restarting it and uh I am a part of this
program page if you click on the link of
this program you can look the
registration costs and pick the level
that works the best for you
thank you so much
once a person has joined the program
then this is what they see like they can
uh watch the recording complete the
session and this is how the recording
comes up and also you get to click on
the zoom button to join the zoom meeting
directly from the program page itself
the session is pending yeah so that was
it over to you
there is one more query that is please
share information about research
Fellowship will that involve training
yes definitely a research Fellowship
involves training you can't straight
away work with uh your research question
in hand uh if you don't have the
required skill set if you don't know
about the concepts involved or the
algorithms involved or you if you don't
have a hands up with the pipeline but if
you have a good Hands-On practice and if
you have completed
um the initial training with us already
then you can straight away start with
the research fellowship program so the
research fellowship program is for uh
either three months or six months the
outcomes of both of these durations are
different obviously in six months you
are giving me more time to your research
fellowship and the outcome could
definitely be as publication and uh the
three months program you will be able to
uh work on a poster presentation maybe
that you that you can present in any of
the conferences and also competitions
all right now what is the structure
basically so in the first month you go
through the training process you meet
the mentor uh twice every week take your
doubts from the mentor and proceed ahead
and then when you have to work on your
research project once your training is
completed all the all dogs are clarified
and you have a good Hands-On practice
with the pipelines as well on the T by
info server after that you're supposed
to submit a research proposal to us so
udb literature and come up with a
question that you would like to work on
if you don't have a question with you
that you would like to work on but you
have an idea what exactly you want to
work then Mentor will help you uh just
design your question design a framework
for you and then get you started with
your research question research project
sorry now once you get started with your
research project it Remains the Same
that you will be meeting the mentor
twice every week to update the mentor
with your progress to clarify a question
that you might have and discuss the next
steps and these meetings are one way
that we communicate and we have Skype
groups set up for each research fellow
so you are in touch with the mentor uh
24 7 on weekday specifically where you
can ask the mentor your question or
mention the step where you are stuck and
will be there to help you out and if
there is a meeting required in between
apart from the two live meetings then
you can ask us and we'll be there to
help you out with that
this is just a glimpse of what I have
shared there's a lot that happens in a
research fellowship meeting and
um
other the program definitely so we'll be
shortly organizing a research Fellowship
webinar as well where we'll discuss
about different specialization tracks as
well on which we are working so there
are six different specialization tracks
on which we are working I I'll just take
few minutes and give you and give you a
brief overview so one of them is uh
sorry oncology then we have then we also
work on Precision medicine infectious
diseases space omics agriculture
biotechnology
and neurosciences is one of them as well
so these are some of the fields that we
are working on and apply obviously omics
data analysis skill sets uh so that that
is what we are working on this is just a
just a very brief overview of the
specialization tracks and we'll be
discussing more about it in detail in
the webinar
so if you are interested in the research
fellowship program what you can do is
just open up this program page and maybe
submit your interest if you click over
here register program interest you
submit your interest and whenever we
have this webinar uh you just receive an
invitation you can join and then take up
your questions
um metagenomic analysis on your water
samples working to determine the Iowa
community structure of some water bodies
and
So when you say your your samples
did you collect these samples and get
them sequenced and do you have your own
data that that you want to work with
uh you can unmute yourself if I think so
yes you can yeah please go ahead
I can't hear you
[Music]
I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing your
name uh right either yes I can hear you
now thank you yes I said I'm planning to
pull up the water samples you know I
cannot just collect water samples
without sequencing immediately
I'm storing it appropriately so I'm
planning to collect water samples so and
I actually want to get it from
knowledgeable by informatics
and do you come from a buying schematics
background and do you already have an
idea about what pipelines you could run
and
um like which all are the algorithms
involved for the analysis do you already
have an idea or not no I don't uh it's
actually part of my thesis
so and um
it's part of what I meant to do
in order to complete my PhD work so and
I want to learn as I'm here
got it so uh for you I would recommend
the metagenomics program maybe so here
is the metagenomics program and in this
program uh we will first of all get you
trained and help you understand what is
the metagenomics data about all right
and uh then we'll discuss about various
pipelines that you can use there are uh
two very popular pipelines for
metagenomic data analysis one is data
two and then another one is kind two
which helps you look at the microbial
abundances of your microbial communities
in these samples and then also calculate
Alpha and beta diversity and also look
at the taxonomic opponents that's okay
that that's what I mentioned and then
also you calculate the code Matrix all
right so the distances for each one of
the examples all right so there is a lot
that you covered in metagenomics so uh
here is the program page for the Mega
genomic data analysis program the
program already commenced yesterday we
had the first session please drop your
email address in the chat box we'll
share the uh recording of the first
session with you and you can follow
along the
sessions scheduled here to understand
what will topics are we going to cover
and uh how this programmers should be
able to give you an understanding and
talking about the research aspect you
said you're going to have your own
samples all right so when you have your
own samples uh we can facilitate an FTP
account setting for you where you can
upload your uh samples and then use the
sea Links of those samples location to
run these pipelines on the T via info
server and help you with your analysis
all right so I will suggest that you
pick the 90 day subscription level
because your model first research
project that you want to work on after
the training process is over and uh a b
uh are also providing scholarship for
this program too so the same form you
can fill for this program as well all
right you just need to pick the program
okay just
so we just fill this form and drop in
your email address so that we can share
with you the details and we can uh help
you with a good scholarship to get
started
welcome
are there any uh charges for metagenomic
hackathon registration
yes there are charges involved for
metagenomics hackathon registration uh
and we are going to launch the program
next week and will be uh discussing
about the charges in detail then as well
but I'll just give you an idea about
that so are individual is registering
its dollar hundred and if a group of a
group of three people are registering
for the hackathon then it would be
dollar 300 and these group of three
people should be like one should be a
researcher and the another one should be
from computer science background and the
third one should have uh a business
background all right or maybe an
understanding of um how to
apply the
um project that you work on to a
business center and if you don't have uh
the two partners or one of them that you
could uh make a group with and register
maybe you can register individually and
then we can help you get into a group
and then start working with your uh
analysis and then finally apply it to to
the industrial aspects
yes that's pretty much about hackathon
and Ola is asking
uh do you have students in building
their own tools
so that will again be a part of the
research fellowship program Ola and uh
Dr ragher would you like to add on to
ola's question
sorry what's the question do you help
students in building their own tools yes
we uh if you are going to sign up for a
research fellowship program and then
depending upon what you can understand
what you can achieve within that time
frame for building up these tools so we
um
to address on the possibility of such a
project we have to get up or we have to
set up a separate meeting with you Ola
so it depends on the complexity of the
question it depends on what you want to
write or what you want to include in
these tools and what are the analysis
steps that you want to include and what
you want to analyze so uh yeah
um if you if you don't want to be
specific in this public form you can get
in touch with us using supported point
of Bio or you can yeah you can also uh
yeah write to supported bind.bio if you
are free to set up a meeting with us we
can we can go about by understanding
more about more specific information
about what you want to do and how
feasible it is within their framework of
research fellowship program okay
foreign
can you hear me yes I can hear you yes
please go ahead
um
I'm from Nigeria yeah I'm a medical
laboratory scientists I have a fashion
and bioinformatics especially infectious
bioinformatics
so I am asking what are the basic
requirements for someone that wanted to
start a bio a career in a bioinformatics
with a molecular biology background
okay if you if you want to start up a
carrier in bioinformatics background you
you have to find ways to expand your
knowledge in some sort of coding I don't
have to learn many things but learning
one coding language will help you
associate with the others also so
bioinformatics skills mainly involves
using different analysis methods and
then mending these analysis methods to
suit your data and the question that you
are studying so for this you can start
with understanding the logic behind this
analysis method in several of the
resources that we are sharing with you
and if you have an environment like
Talbot bioinfo platform and within what
this platform offers you you can start
with code free analysis of
bioinformatics data analysis but
eventually if you want to be a separate
bioinformatician you have to get
yourself
familiarized yeah you have to get
yourself familiarized in one coding
language preferably r or python
depending upon your
nature and your comfort level okay
okay thank you very much
thank you so much everyone so with that
I would like to conclude today's webinar
thank you everyone for your patience and
time and I hope to see you all for
session one of the data science program
and if you have any further queries I
have shared the details of the marketing
manager you can reach out to her via her
email ID or her phone number which is
also active on WhatsApp so thank you
everyone have a great day
[Music]